all right I've done the
friends-with-benefits movie starring the
white swan now we'll do the one starring
the Black Swan friends with benefits
I'll try not to compare this movie to
no-strings-attached as much as I can but
in the end I'm gonna end up doing it a
bit you have to alright so friends with
benefits is a story of Mila Kunis and
Justin Timberlake two people who are
emotionally damaged they've had their
hearts broken so they're emotionally
unavailable they're done with the dating
scene I saw the two become really good
friends and then Timberlake throws out
something that most anyone would in that
situation which is pretty much hey
really hot chick who doesn't want to get
attached let's have sex and not get
attached and so they do and what I
really liked about this movie is it was
really funny to see that it was just all
business with them but like talking and
having like normal conversation and
interacting like friends while they're
having sex and who wouldn't be down with
that if your friend was Mila Kunis but
inevitably when you embark on something
like this you do get to all you hopefuls
out there you can't do this situation
and not have drama no and Justin
Timberlake soon learns what I've always
said and that is that women are like the
board you get one shot after that they
adapt and you're done resistance is
futile if you take nothing else away
from this review remember that now I'm
gonna level with you guys I really
enjoyed friends-with-benefits I mean
it's as predictable as a rom-com like
this goes if you've seen
no-strings-attached you pretty much know
exactly how this is gonna play out but
it is a little different I like Justin
Timberlake and Mila Kunis's relationship
in the movie you really actually buy the
fact that they are friends they're pals
usually movies fail on that point but in
this one I really could tell that they
are best friends and people are gonna be
like oh it's just some raunchy comedy
about sex well yeah but it's a funny
rated-r raunchy comedy about sex and
that ain't nothing and I really like the
dialogue in the movie the script I
thought was well-written Mila Kunis and
Justin Timberlake's dialogue between
each other and their banter back and
forth was really awesome it's like that
relationship that guys ideally wants
that's why people watch them mad about
you in the 90s and I sincerely think
this movie forgetting criss cross stuck
in my head all day which I also found
funny because there's always those
things out there that band that you like
when you were young you don't really
talk about it but everyone knows you
have that one not that I remember any
New Kids on the Block lyrics that would
be weird but it's kids for this week is
sick and kids had a twist out of Kim
we're gonna forget that ever happened
but you know you have the group that you
keep a secret - the only supporting
character and friends with benefits that
was really funny was Woody Harrelson
he's not in it much but he's so gay it's
absurd
the rest of the supporting characters
are family which are therefore that
emotional part of the movie and it is
actually kind of emotional there's some
stuff with Timberlake's dad that he has
to deal with it actually you're like oh
that's touching considering is to
rated our ranch comedy revolving around
sex it surprised me so in the end I'm
going to say this movie is a good time
no alcohol acquired which is the same
rating I gave no strings attached when
it came out but as a movie I thought
friends-with-benefits was actually
better than no strings attached I like
the relationship between Mila Kunis and
Justin Timberlake more than I liked
Ashton Kutcher and Natalie Portman I
thought Natalie Portman carried no
strings attached she could have had a
no-strings-attached relationship with
like a zucchini I wouldn't have known it
wasn't good sure so if you like no
strings attached friends-with-benefits i
thought was better so I said go check it
out if you don't like rated our comedies
about sex you probably shouldn't watch
it those just be the facts so no strings
attached for friends-with-benefits have
you seen both what one did you prefer
comment below let me know and who do you
think's hotter Mila Kunis or Natalie
Portman that is a legit question my
choice I'm gonna be honest with you I
refilmed this part after finding that
picture cuz that pictures awesome she
just looks like evil like she'd make it
worth it if I picked her so Natalie
Portman and if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]